you have lost very very few times in
your career
uh one
i mean this is the same is true for
george and uh the only person who has
ever submitted you is felipe pena black
belt yeah a black bow
he is a dcc world champion multiple time
ibj jjf guillotine world champion
you may face him a dcc or elsewhere in
the future um
will you beat him
uh yes i mean i have to say yes right um
but uh
i fought him initially when i first got
my black belt um that i fought him a
year later so 2016 and 2017 um and
despite what people remember about the
match
and whenever people talk about it's like
oh yeah the guy who strangled gordon but
no one remembers that the first match
was like a 45 minute war
um and then the second match with the
full 20 minutes of adcc and if i didn't
get my back taken in like the last
minute and a half two minutes it would
have went into an overtime that could
change the outcome of the match
um
i think that if you look at felipe's
performances especially nogi
specifically nogi since then it looks
like he's almost gotten worse whereas
since that match
uh in 2017
uh the only match i lost after that was
against vinnie uh magalesh by my points
and uh
i'm on like a 55 match win streak
over the course of four years
winning all the major tournaments nogi
and felipe since that match i think is
like five and two uh nogi um and he's
lost his last two match matches one was
convincingly where he was dominated by
andre and one was by submission um so i
don't think that he's progressed nearly
as fast if anything he looks like he's
worse than he was when he beat me in
2017 based on his previous performances
um that being said i know he's going to
come in
training very hard for this one and he's
going to be prepared but i just don't
think
that
in terms of technical ability he's
anywhere near my level and
he was much bigger than me
both times we fought
the first time he was much bigger i mean
the second time he was one weight class
above me
so now there's not going to be an
advantage in
technicality and it's also not going to
be a physicality advantage so i think
he's just going to be beat everywhere
this is uh this is a good example of the
scientific response to a um
to a comment to a question yeah so he's
not um
that's a match you're you're not deeply
concerned with
in terms of the set of opponents because
you you you have and you will be facing
a lot of really difficult yeah that's
actually in my opinion one of the easier
matches because of the fact that we're
relatively the same size
um if i show up at 230 pounds like a lot
of the guys are
260 270 plus so that extra weight does
make a difference i think out of that
entire bracket um
felipe is probably going to be the one
of the easiest matches because of the
fact that i can easily take him down and
if i take him out i'm going to pass his
guard whereas i feel like the other guys
because they're so much bigger and
they're very cagey
it may take me a while to actually
take them to the ground
and get on top of them and i think it
may be they may be longer drawn out
matches because of the fact that they're
so much bigger and stally it's hard to
take them down but felipe's relatively
my size and his wrestling is atrocious
so and i've already taken them down in
the last adcc match so i'm pretty sure i
can just easily put them down pass them
and then finish them
well i'm not sure what response i was
expecting but uh that was those phrases
beautifully